McDAVID AND DRAISAITL.
THESE ARE GOING TO BE TOUGH WAS
EDMONTON COMES THE OTHER WAY.
TWO-ON-ONE!
McDAVID WITH KANE!
KANE CAN'T GET IT TO HIM.
OUT IN FRONT!
FIND YAMAMOTO ALL ALONE.
GREAT SHOT ON GLOVE THERE.
HITS  BE SO EXCITING THIS
YEAR.
SO MANY TEAMS HAOPPORTUNITY
FOR CECI.
GOOD JOB AT THE BLUE LINE. E WI
OPPORTUNITY.
WOULD HAVE BEEN A GOOD WARIGHT
>> Steve: CEMcDAVID AND TENDER
KLOBUCHAR!
THE OILERS SCORE 1st AND TAKE A
OTHERS, BECAUSE WHAT ARE THEY
NOW, 20 1-0 WHEN THEYGOING
THIS GAME 1-0.
>> Steve: HERE'S BOUCHARD.
SEE HIS SKILLS ON DISPBENN.
ROBERTSON HAS BEEN IT THIS
YEAR.
A PIECE FOR HEISKANEN, FRONT OF
SMART HOCKEY FORECHECK SHOT, AN
WHAT A SAVE MY KOTO JAMIE BENN
2-1.
>> Steve: HINTZ COULDN'T GEBREA
HE'S GOT THE  IT ON COMING TO T
TAKEN AWAY, TURNS IT OVER! IT!
>> Mark: HASN'T BEEN IT.
A GREAT SET UP TO KANE IN FRONT
OF THE NET .
>> Steve: NOT SURE
SEVENTH SHORT-HANDED GOAL ON
THE CAMPAIGN FOR EDMONTON.
RIGHT
AS WELL.
JUST WE WERE SCORES!
SPECTACULAR GOAL!  ACROSS!
SCORED!
AND IT'S DRAISAITL FOR!
JUST LIKE THAT, THE STARS
RECLAIM THE LEAD!
IT'S
PRESSING THE LANES.
LIKE I
EMPTY NET FOR BENN!
IT HITS THE PIPE!
I D
IN!
EMPTY-THAT GOAL, DALLAS!